[Música]
en primera plana
carlos cerrada
bienvenidos en primera plana un programa
de radio francia internacional y de
france 24 esta semana ponemos el foco en
las nuevas relaciones entre eeuu y
latinoamérica a partir de la llegada de
joe biden a la casa blanca para ello me
acompañan en este estudio dos invitados
pascal dúo exprés es presidente de la
asociación la trama francia américa
latina y especialista en la región
bienvenido pas cancers contamos también
con cristo aventura director de
investigación en el instituto de
relaciones internacionales y
estratégicas especialista en
latinoamérica bienvenido christophe muy
buenos días y en dúplex desde nueva york
nos acompaña también nuestra
corresponsal si él viene a este link
silvina buenos días
muy buenos días las nuevas relaciones
entre eeuu y latinoamérica a partir de
la llegada de joe biden al poder hoy en
primera plana
[Música]
bueno pues vaivén impulsa un complicado
giro en la política estadounidense hacia
américa latina la nueva administración
buscará más cooperación aunque eso sí
excluye cambios bruscos en venezuela o
cuba su primer desafío ya lo tiene con
una crisis una nueva crisis migratoria
en la frontera con mexico la llegada de
miles de menores satura la capacidad de
acogida en un asunto especialmente
sensible en febrero hubo 100.000
detenciones en la frontera un aumento
del 28 por ciento respecto al mes
anterior
muchos de esos migrantes además son
menores no acompañados que huyen de la
pobreza y de la violencia en
centroamérica todo adelantado por las
dificultades económicas agravadas por la
pandemia vamos a repasar algunas de las
portadas de la prensa que nos dejan
estas relaciones revista foreign affairs
latinoamérica eeuu regresa al mundo un
análisis de la nueva política
hemisférica de byd en revista semana en
colombia no problem algunos piensan que
las relaciones entre eeuu y colombia
está en peligro dice el semanario desde
la llegada de bailén pero esto no es así
milenio se hacía eco de una primera
llamada de amlo abaid en después de que
éste ganara las elecciones en noviembre
pasado amlo le decía el rotativo
recuerda a byd en el proyecto migratorio
que pactó contra en bueno señor duro
hasta qué punto podemos hablar de un
cambio en las relaciones entre eeuu y
latinoamérica a partir de la llegada de
joe biden al poder creo que el cambio
aparece en términos de imagen desde que
entró robado en la casa blanca tenía que
mostrar una ruptura la ruptura fue árabe
sobre el frente podemos interior con la
temática de la pared a la frontera de
méxico pero también por supuesto
recordando que conoce bien en américa
latina sea yo bailén fue presidente de
la comisión de asuntos exteriores del
senado se fue mucho por américa latina'
de raíz de esos 20 últimos años así fue
también como vicepresidente y nombrando
a responsables los nuevos responsables
de la administración norteamericana
encargada de la
relaciones con américa latina estoy
pensando obviamente en uan sebastián
gonzález en consejo nacional y si corría
señor ventura está claro que la ahora
mismo la prioridad de joe biden es la
pandemia pero qué importancia cree que
le otorga el nuevo presidente de eeuu a
las relaciones con américa latina bueno
yo creo que hablamos de un presidente
que es el presidente que conoce lo más a
latinoamérica desde los primeros
presidentes de eeuu es un gran conocedor
de la región como se sabe pero yo pienso
que la relación a latinoamérica estará
la prioridad de la administración byron
pero es la zona de influencia
tradicional no histórica de eeuu y yo
creo que para washington lo más
importante sería estar a tener esta zona
tranquila para no dejar a china y un
poco a rusia pero sobre todo a china
el espacio para avanzar
en el continente americano es el enfoque
principal de su política en el futuro y
creó un gran conocedor y muy interesante
este apunte de china y de su influencia
en la región vamos a ir si me lo
permiten en este punto hasta nueva york
con nuestra corresponsal
silvina este link silvina la crisis
migratoria que estos días está
sacudiendo la frontera con mexico
agravada por la pandemia no sé si
podríamos decir que es el primer gran
gran reto que tiene badén sobre la mesa
bueno buena pregunta carlos la verdad
que esta situación de crisis en la
frontera sur del país en la frontera con
méxico es no solamente el primer gran
desafío para el presidente de bailén
sino también el primer gran problema hay
más de 500 chicos que llegan a diario a
la frontera con mexico y realmente el
sistema está saturado y ximo entonces lo
que estamos viendo es una especie de
regreso a las políticas
de la hera trump cuando en realidad el
presidente joe vaivén había prometido
y reparar un sistema migratorio quebrado
baiden enfrenta el desafío de poder
respetar a menos de tres meses de haber
asumido lo que él prometió en la época
de campaña silvina by the end se
encuentra sin duda en una encrucijada
los sectores más progresistas de su
partido alertan sobre el trato que
puedan recibir estos menores y los más
moderados temen que la inmigración
ilegal sea el gran ángulo de ataque de
los republicanos para las legislativas
cruciales de 2022 de momento el equipo
de baile inculpa la administración tram
como decías diciendo que desmanteló
completamente el sistema de asilo pero a
medio y largo plazo cuál va a ser la
estrategia de vaivén
esa es una pregunta clave por supuesto
que ahora la prioridad es donde albergar
a estos chicos y estas familias con
niños menores y adolescentes que están
llegando casi en estampida a la frontera
entonces es verdad que hay que reabrir
centros de albergues y refugios que en
la era trans fueron cerrados cuál es el
problema
esos centros no siempre tienen licencias
es imposible entonces cuando surge un
problema
adjudicar responsabilidades estamos en
pandemia hay que asegurarse que las
personas que están en esos centros
puedan tener acceso a protocolos de
pruebas de kobe y tengan recursos son
niños o sea que es mucho más difícil que
dar albergue a adultos no entonces la
solución de esto que va y dénia la está
tomando por ejemplo cuando abrió puso
sobre el tapete el plan por ejemplo de
abrir el centro de convenciones de
dallas para albergar a 3.000
adolescentes y también por ejemplo
muchas que sumó la firma no a la agencia
federal de manejo de emergencias para
que suministre agua para que de
alimentos todas esas son soluciones que
tuvo que tomar maiden pero que no lucen
bien no se refuerzan o machacan esta
postal de crisis a poco de haber asumido
entonces realmente esa es una
herramienta que pueden usar los
republicanos a la hora de socavar la
legitimidad de bailén de cara a las
elecciones del año que viene las
elecciones de medio término legislativas
donde apuntan
a sacarle arrebatarle el control
demócrata de ambas cámaras a los
demócratas cuando entonces eso por un
lado el tema del asilo y la crisis en la
frontera por otro están los dreamers y
qué hacer con los más de 11 millones de
indocumentados que ya están en
territorio de eeuu y a los que se viene
prometiendo un camino a la ciudadanía
hace largo tiempo entonces esta crisis
en la frontera sobre todo va a tener un
impacto en esa gente en esos
indocumentados que ya están acá en el
país
primark trabajadores de la cosecha que
lamentablemente van a estar los que se
resientan más por el no poder superar o
dar solución inmediata a la cristianidad
en la frontera
silvina proceso que la cámara de
representantes de eeuu ha aprobado ese
proyecto de ley que contempla la
creación de una vida para la
nacionalidad de millones de inmigrantes
sin documentos
benítez claro aún todavía de la
tramitación en el senado
no sé señor duro parte de esta
estrategia quizá pase también por un
impulso a la cooperación en
centroamérica y de inversiones en
centroamericano
con centroamérica y diría de manera
general con américa latina pero
específicamente con centroamérica
definitivamente el punto justamente de
ruptura con la administración trump es
acabar con esos acuerdos del cert said
country que se aplicaron desde hace dos
años entre washington y varias capitales
de centroamérica dentro de la cual es
guatemala
es decir impedir que los migrantes
salgan de los países donde están de
pasando para volver a la frontera sur de
la frontera norte hacia méxico
contrí se está acabando y eso es un
definitivamente es una medida muy fuerte
con centroamérica ahora ojo el verdadero
desafío y que es una correlación en
materia de política interior es el hecho
de que la crisis que está atardeciendo
centroamérica pero américa latina
ponemos en general pone realmente en
tela de juicio los términos de
cooperación está apareciendo una forma
de atomización completa de américa
latina no es un conjunto un continente
unido américa latina la característica
del continente es la diversidad me está
hablando de carlos de centroamérica pero
centroamérica tiene tantas realidades
como su número de países
y eso es la gran característica y creo
que el gran desafío de la administración
de byron es esta cómo crear un mínimo de
uno de unidad en un continente que se
está realmente atomizando quizá lo que
lo que aportaba antes christophe es algo
que sea un gran conocedor de la región
vaivén por lo menos en la teoría puede
ayudar a esto que estaba comentando
pascal no visto sí claro
byron conoce tiene muy claro los
desafíos de la región y es claro que
para él su en su orden de prioridades no
primero centroamérica porque es el
núcleo de su hoja de ruta
latinoamericana es claramente de
centroamérica porque por razones de
política interior
primero de todo temas de inmigración
temas de violencia de narco de crimen
organizado etcétera
eso es para washington un tema de
política interior y es la razón por la
cual vamos a ver que centroamérica
estarás el centro de su acción en
latinoamérica
porque obviamente este problema que nos
está hablando pascal de manera muy
precisa es que latinoamérica falta de
unidad regional iii para el método de
vaivén que quería
digamos dinamizar una visión
multilateral de los problemas de los
temas
para arreglarlos es un problema porque
con quién hablar en latinoamérica eso es
un es un tema para washington a hablar
con centroamérica es bastante fácil pero
hablar con latinoamérica es otro tema la
doctrina de trampa en américa latina se
fundamentó en la idea de esa troika
tiránica que englobaba venezuela cuba y
nicaragua mucho discurso guerrero pero
lo tangible fueron sanciones contra el
núcleo de maduro ahora la administración
bailén subraya en los pocos frutos que
esa estrategia ha brindado pero tampoco
hay que esperar cambios bruscos quizás
pascal
ahí todo está mezclado de verdad y lo
vimos durante esos últimos cuatro años
con venezuela a la vez fue el blando
número uno de la administración en tremp
intentó movilizar los países de américa
latina y dentro lo cual es uno de la
alianza del pacífico pienso por supuesto
en el presidente de chile y obviamente
el país vecino de venezuela colombia
imagínense colombia-venezuela es un poco
la relación francia-alemania es decir
que es una relación absolutamente
indispensable pero por cierto pues
fueron sanciones fue una electricidad
regional muy grande y los resultados que
queda al final de cuatro años micro
maduro están ahí poder en unos instantes
les voy a preguntar por estar unas
relaciones con venezuela y con cuba va a
ser a la vuelta de pausa que en primera
plana
[Música]
la falta de reconocimiento del
matrimonio homosexual es
inconstitucional lo aclarado esta semana
un tribunal de sapporo con una sentencia
que supone el primer paso hacia su
legalización será un camino largo y
pedregoso porque exigirá la aprobación
de una ley pero la comunidad lgtb te
juzgó la jornada ya como histórica la
sentencia llega después de que 13
parejas homosexuales presentaran una
denuncia por discriminación el día de
san valentín de 2019 alegando que no
podían disfrutar de derechos como el de
heredar el tribunal les da la razón y se
espera que influya en los casos
pendientes japón es el único país del g7
que no reconoce los matrimonios
homosexuales y de hacerlo se convertiría
en el segundo de asia hasta ahora sólo
los admite taiwán una democracia
ejemplar en materia de derechos civiles
y que a pesar de eso tuvo que vencer
todas las reticencias conservadoras
antes de aprobarlo en 2019
[Música]
el grupo de la comunidad lgtb que sufren
irán son los homosexuales por un lado
están las autoridades especialmente la
policía que nos puede atacar en el
espacio público o entrar a sus casas
muchas veces los puede tener no por
acusados de homosexualidad pero sí de
dañar la tranquilidad en el espacio
público y también por sus familias que
los acusaban de deshonra de dañar la
imagen de la familia nos ponen al lado
muchas veces los de cerebral y no les
vuelven a hablar estaba totalmente en
contra de lo que pasa con los
transexuales que están permitidos en
irán después de una factura del ayatolá
jomeiní 1979 incluso después de un
examen psicológico el estado puede
ayudar a financiar la operación de
cambio de sexo y también de cambio de
identidad de estas personas pero esto
también tiene problemas porque muchos
homosexuales no ven otra salida que
cambiarse de sexo algo que no quieren
hacer de antemano trayendo grandes
consecuencias mentales
[Música]
sudáfrica es el único país del
continente africano donde es legal el
matrimonio igualitario y después de la
caída de la parte y la nueva
constitución sudafricana sería la
primera en el mundo en prohibir la
discriminación a los homosexuales
más adelante en 2006 sudáfrica se
convertiría en el quinto país en aprobar
el matrimonio para personas del mismo
sexo durante la parte de la
homosexualidad criminalizada y casta
queda hasta con siete años de prisión
pero hoy en día en áreas urbanas
especialmente aquí la ciudad del cabo y
especialmente aquí en el barrio de green
point es donde nos encontramos ahora se
presenta una amplia oferta para la
comunidad lgtb del mundo incluso se
ofrecen paquetes turísticos que buscan
atraer a miembros de esta comunidad a
visitar la ciudad sin embargo en las
áreas menos favorecidas especialmente en
la periferia urbana se presentan aún
grandes desafíos para la comunidad lgtb
y sobre todo cuando hablamos de
episodios de violencia homofóbica y de
altas tasas de vih sudáfrica también es
un centro receptor de inmigrantes
y de países de áfrica subsahariana donde
la homosexualidad es criminalizada entre
los cuales se encuentran sin bagua
uganda y tanzania
[Música]
france24 punto com está disponible en
cuatro idiomas artículos reportajes
noticias internacionales continuamente
todas nuestras ediciones para ver de
nuevo y el canal en directo 24 horas los
7 días intuitivo rápido y en cuatro
lenguas france24 puntocom liberté
égalité actualice
seguimos en primera plana esta semana
hablando de las nuevas relaciones entre
eeuu y latinoamérica a partir de la
llegada de joe biden al poder o lo
hacemos con pascal duro o presidente de
la asociación francia américa latina con
cristo aventura director de
investigación relaciones internaciones
estratégicas en el instituto de
relaciones internacionales y
estratégicas y desde nueva york nuestra
corresponsal silvina sterling estábamos
hablando de las relaciones de bailén con
venezuela con cuba con esa troika negra
que presentó trump durante su mandato
como va a ser la presión de vaivén hacia
nicolás maduro para que convoquen nuevas
elecciones christophe edades que no
tienen muchas muchas cosas en su manos y
puedo decir para hacerlo
el tema es que este by donde reconoce la
que la estrategia de washington con wide
o
no funcionó eso es un tema muy claro
pero por el momento yo creo que no se va
a hacer muchas cosas sobretodo byron
porque tiene que evaluar un valorizar un
poquito la situación yo creo que están
un poco bloqueados con whitehall porque
lo reconocen como presidente de
venezuela aún que bueno no tenga ninguna
posición institucional ahora porque está
fuera de la asamblea bueno yo pienso que
eeuu se van a esperar un poquito se van
a cambiar digamos el perfil de sus
medidas unilaterales en contra de
venezuela se van a apoyar más en el
sector humanitario dejar a menos sabemos
que querían salir del país la
posibilidad de aprovechar las de la nube
del nuevo marco de la inmigración
norteamericana y se van a tolerar
digamos oa dejar la posibilidad yo creo
de un dialogo en una nueva negociación
en venezuela con todos los actores
incluso la parte del gobierno con
facilidad horas internacionales como el
grupo de noruega u otro yo creo que se
van a dejar las cosas así esperando para
pero para no tener un papel directo en
el conflicto venezolano y yo pienso que
se van a actuar así
louis vamos eso con respecto a venezuela
con respecto a cuba volvemos a nueva
york con este punto con nuestra
corresponsal silvina sterling que se
espera de las nuevas relaciones entre la
casa blanca y la habana el tema es el
timing el tiempo que tan prioritario es
el tema cuba ahora para bailén eso es
una gran incógnita que seguramente va a
ser mejor que cuando estaba trump no hay
dudas o sea va a ir en
fue muy presente en toda esta época de
hielo que protagonizó obama bailén
estaba allí y sin ir más lejos alejandro
mayorkas es cubano y es ahora el
secretario del departamento de seguridad
nacional eso es un un gran este es una
gran señal que le daba al gobierno de
cuba
hay muchos académicos y escritores
artistas que le han pedido a bailén que
por favor levante el embargo que por
favor revierta las sanciones también
está por supuesto el lobby cubano
americano que no es menor y que también
puja porque por ejemplo baiden continúe
poniendo a cuba en la lista de países
que patrocinan el terrorismo entonces es
un poco esa puja entre los que aprietan
a bailén porque vuelva a este deshielo
de la era de obama y continúe con esas
reformas de flexibilización y los que le
piden a bailén que presione la isla
porque libere a presos políticos porque
le dé mayores libertades fundamentales a
sus ciudadanos así que
creo que todavía es muy prematuro para
ver cómo irán estas relaciones pero que
en el futuro se van a flexibilizar
probablemente
gracias a silvina y pascal quien va a
ganar en esta puja que nos contaba
silvina esa va haber una continuidad con
esa etapa de deshielo de la era obama de
la cual va a tener al vicepresidente joe
biden está confrontado en dos temáticas
muy sencillas con tener eso es la
urgencia es hoy contener contener la
temática de materia de seguridad
contener riesgo a nivel electoral
interno en cuba obviamente es un tema lo
sabemos desde diseños y a la vez lanzar
pues una forma proyectarse favorecer
unos nuevos ejes que impulsen una nueva
dinámica podemos esperar definitivamente
con cuba y con empresas no volvieras a
empresas por ejemplo de la
agroalimentación o que están vinculadas
con cuba no olviden la temática
energética la planta eléctrica de
matanzas ahí cerquita de la habana
necesita rehabilitación se necesita
electricidad y allí son canales
nuevos en los cuales los eeuu pueden ya
llegar a inyectar una presencia nueva
vaivén pretende un mayor compromiso que
su antecesor con los derechos humanos
pero atención porque la crisis económica
post pandemia puede alzar voces
populistas en el continente creen que la
actitud de defensa de la democracia de
bailén será cuanto menos más activa que
la de trump
sí claro porque hay donde nuevo encarna
está esta tradición de eeuu de aparecer
como la potencia de la democracia en su
forma liberal al nivel interior como al
nivel internacional en el sistema
mundial y de este punto de vista byron
está en la tradición diplomática de los
estados unidos cuando trump estaba más
en la ruptura con esa tradición bueno
una vez dicho eso
podrá hacerlo o no eso eso es otro tema
como eeuu hoy en día pueden realmente
lograr cumplir esos objetivos es otra
cosa porque él se va a tener tan
desafíos internos con un país fracturado
con un pueblo norteamericano muy
dividido como como hamás no con el
tropismo que existe como fuerza todavía
tan fuerte en el país más allá de donald
trump como tal bueno eso es un tema
los problemas económicos sanitarios
están tan fuertes en el país que yo
quiero decir que el agenda interior
estará tan y movilizador para byron que
su capacidad internacional su política
exterior
está cuestionada por la prioridad
interna y eso yo creo que vamos a
descubrirlo más concretamente en el
futuro lo que pasa es que claro a raíz
de la post pandemia pueden alzarse voces
populistas pero también la posición de
eeuu sermoneando a favor de la
democracia después de las imágenes que
vimos en el capitolio no sé si este será
el mejor momento en la mente es la razón
por la cual el hoy en día la la vía no
es la vía contractual definitivamente se
va a favorecer creo el vínculo nacional
unilateral más allá de lo multilateral y
regional con américa latina' va a pasar
contra tu país por país porque como
decíamos desde ya más o menos desde por
lo menos que empezó la la pandemia los
países están atomizando la realidad se
está volviendo inédita nunca tuvimos
desde hace un año tantos candidatos que
se declaran independientes
llegan llegando de sectores de la
sociedad civil que no han tocado a la
política y que toman el poder y lo
ejercen finalmente de manera bastante
autoritaria lo estamos viendo con allí
bukele en el salvador por ejemplo el
salvador que tiene una relación muy
fuerte con los eeuu
y ese es eso plantea una atmósfera
piense nicaragua una atmósfera muy
particular que demuestra que se tiene
que hacer contrato por contrato país por
país
en nueva yor silvina corresponsal de ref
y la prioridad ahora mismo de bailén lo
contábamos antes no es otra que la
pandemia pero qué importancia creen que
otorga la administración a nueva
administración a las relaciones de
cooperación con toda la región
latinoamericana silvina la relación de
latinoamérica con la casa blanca bueno
todo un tema por supuesto la región
recibió como una bocanada de aire fresco
al triunfo de vaivén y la relación entre
la región de latinoamérica con la casa
blanca sólo puede mejorar en cuanto a
los pilares en los que va a cursar esta
relación son por supuesto la lucha
contra el cambio climático el fomento de
la democracia y el respeto por los
derechos humanos en este sentido por
ejemplo bailén ya se pronunció contra
venezuela se refirió a nicolás madura
como hundir al dictador brutal y acaba
recientemente de darle la posibilidad a
venezolanos que están en eeuu de acceder
a una protección temporal quizás con
vías de encaminar a la ciudadanía ahora
qué pasa hay dos cuestiones
el poder moral tiene eeuu después de lo
que pasó el 3 de enero en el capitolio
en muchos países latinoamericanos que lo
cuestionan y dicen eeuu es un país
bananero más y por otro lado la pandemia
eeuu todavía tiene que mirar hacia
adentro para recuperarse del gran
desempleo que dejó el kobryn 19 y de la
recesión y después se verá si tiene el
resto para lanzarlo en salvavidas a la
región de latinoamérica gracias silvina
lo apuntaba antes
christophe esas relaciones esa
influencia de china en la región no
quería dejarla pasar por alto en una
américa latina donde crece la presencia
de china y donde tram practicó apenas
una diplomacia casi podríamos decirlo
personal de intercambio de valores cuál
será la estrategia de bailén para
afrontar esta influencia de china en la
región
pascal o cristo quien quiera y yo creo
que de todas formas de nuevo washington
no podrá regresar a la situación
anterior antes de china se van a tener
la obligación de tener una especie de
coexistencia con china sobre todo en
suramérica
de nuevo eso me parece muy claro que
pueden hacer bueno se va a proponer a
sus socios centroamericanos y
suramericanos un vínculo más fuerte
desde el punto de vista económica es lo
que puede hacer bien byron con la
posibilidad de una inversión más fuerte
del sector privado estadounidense que se
fue de latinoamérica esos últimos 15
años y el regreso del sector privado de
las inversiones norteamericanas de un
apoyo a través del banco interamericano
del desarrollo por ejemplo eso es un
poco lo que puedo pero digo que puede
proponer vaivén para afrontar enfrentar
de una manera limitada a china porque
china tiene un papel tan central es el
primer socio comercial de la región es
el país que presta lo más a los estados
directamente y las diversiones las
inversiones de china se van a alcanzar
los 500 mil
millones de dólares en los próximos tres
o cuatro años es absolutamente enorme
entonces bueno yo pienso que tiene que
que
coexistir ese es el tema algo muy corto
porque estamos ya casi fuera de tiempo
para estar convencido de la coexistencia
lo vimos hace poco en bogotá
quien ganó el metro de bogotá último
metro de con una ciudad de más de 15
millones de habitantes en el mundo por
cierto un consorcio entre china y canadá
pero creo que la el conflicto justamente
se va a ganar sobre las normas sobre la
inteligencia artificial y ahí realmente
los eeuu están delante bueno pues lo
veremos tenemos años por delante para
ver cómo van desarrollándose estas
relaciones entre badén y la región
muchísimas gracias por habernos
acompañado hoy en primera plana ya todos
ustedes hasta la próxima semana muchas
gracias
[Música]